Transcriber: BILAL AL BENNI
المدقّق: gaith Takrity
سأخذكم معي في رحلة جميلة
من الجمود الذهني
والأنا المتسلطة
إلى التفكير التعاوني المؤازر.
تخيل لو أن واحدة من الشركات العملاقة
مثل باتكو أو آبل، مايكروسوفت أو أمازون
نشرت إعلان تبحث فيه عن مدير عام للشركة
أو رئيس للمجموعة،
يا تُرى، هل ستتجرأ للتقدم لها؟
أنا عن نفسي
سأفكر كثيرا قبل التقدم لها
لأنها شركات معقدة
ولديها فروع في كل العالم.
هل تصدقني إن أخبرتك
أنك تقود شركة معقدة
أكثر من تلك الشركات.
نعم،
أنت تقود شركة فيها مئة وخمسين
مليار عامل.
مئة وخمسين مليار !
من أين ااتى كل هؤلاء؟!
كل سكان الكرة الأرضية
لا يصلون إلى ثمانية مليار.
أنا أصر
أنك قادر على قيادة أي شركة تعمل فيها
وتجعلهم جميعا يعملون بنفس التنسيق.
المدير
هو الذي يحدد طريقة العمل.
إذا كان المدير عبقريا
وأدارهم ببراعة أو ذكاء.
كلهم سيعملون بنفس التنسيق؛
ولذلك أبهرتني عبارة لاوتسو عندما قال:
راقب أفكارك لأنها تصير أفعال.
وراقب أفعالك لأنها تصير عادات.
وراقب عاداتك لأنها تصير طباع.
وراقب طباعك لأنه يشكل
شخصيتك ويحدد مصيرك.
هل معقول أن مصيرنا
يتحدد بكلمات وعادات وأفعال!
أمراضنا النفسية،
الجسدية،
العقلية !
الجهود الذهني يصيبنا
حين يتوقف تفكيرنا.
نعم،
ولذلك من الضروري قيادة المعمل الذي في رأسك
الذي فيه مئة مليار خلية عصبية
أنت تتحكم بها
وهي تتحكم في جسمك.
بدأت أبحث
عن إذا كان تفكيرنا يأخذنا للشقاء أو للراحة
للسعادة أو للتعاسة
إذا ما هو الأسلوب الرائع للتفكير؟
بدأت أبحث وأبحث
رأيت الكثير من الأساليب لدى العلماء
وبحثت في أنماط التفكير
والمفكرين
وكنت أتساءل
ما الذي يجعل منطقة شرق آسيا
أفضل منا بالتفكير
وأكثر تعاملا مع بعض
ظل هذا السؤال يحيرني
حتى أخذت دورة القبعات الست في التفكير
وطبقنا هذا على اللغات والعلوم والرياضيات.
عندها علمت لماذا هؤلاء الجماعة
أفضل منا بالتفكير وأكثر تعاونا مع بعض.
وجدت الحل لكل تساؤلاتي
وقررت أن أبدأ مبادرة في المدرسة لمدة سنة
نحول فيها التفكير التنافسي
الذي يعتمد على شخص رابح وشخص خسران
ونتبنى استراتيجية ان الكل رابح
من خلال فكرة ينجزها كل الموجودين،
وكانت فكرة القبعات الست
تعتمد على التفكير المتوازي
وحتى نفكر في أي موضوع
لازم نمر بأكثر من مرحلة
أول مرحلة جمع المعلومات
وتحديد حجمها ومصدرها
من غير استنتاج ولا تحليل
إنما وصف فقط،
والمرحلة الثانية البحث عن إيجابيات الموضوع
او المعلومات ويرمز لها بالقبعة الصفراء
والمرحلة الثالثة حتى لا نبقى حالمين
ولا نحسب العثرات والأزمات والمنطلقات.
لا بد من القبعة السوداء التي تعتبر بحق
رافعة التفكير الإبداعي
والقبعة الحمراء
التي توجد المشاعر التي ترافق المعلومات.
إلى هنا يكون التفكير عاديا ويراعي
المستويات الدنيا من التفكير.
تعالوا معي نرتقي إلى المستويات العليا من
التفكير حيث التفكير الإبداعي
الريادي المثري حيث القبعة الزرقاء.
هذه القبعة تعتمد على المعلومات
وترتيبها وتنظيمها
والقبعة الخضراء هي المرحلة الأرقى
حيث الأفكار الأصلية والمرونة
في التجريب
إلى هنا حيث الأفكار الأصلية
والمرونة في التجريب
اعزائي الحضور أنتم في داخلكم
السكر الذي يحتاج إلى تحريك
حتى تجدوا اثاره.
(تصفيق)